well turning now to Paris where police
have again been firing tear gas and
water cannon as yellow vests protesters
ignited fires and ransacked shops
they're the most violent street clashes
in Paris since December of last year
this is now the fourth month of
demonstrations by a loose coalition of
activists unions and citizens they're
angry with French president Amon omicron
and his policies protesters accuse him
of forgetting about ordinary people and
instead favoring France's police let's
get the latest now from Paris and for
that were joined by journalists John
Lorenson so John what can you tell us
about the current situation in the
French capital there's been a lot of
violence to dance because sudden upsurge
of violence today over the previous
weeks we'd seen a tailing off but today
sudden upsurge we've seen a number of
shots attack solutions in ease in
particular famous marks such as Tara
Jarmon Nespresso Hugo Boss eaten the
land restore we've seen also a nasty
fire which was started by the black bloc
activists these are extreme left
activists extremely well organized
behavior in a quasi-military fashion
today shown demonstrations they attacked
a bank started a fire there eleven
people were injured one woman and her
baby had to be evacuated by firefighters
from the second floor also another thing
to be noted love Phuket's very famous
cafe on the shores ELISA was attacked
ransacked completely wrecked this place
this is very much a symbol of the
political and economic elite in France
it's where Nicolas Sarkozy celebrated
his presidential election election
victory in 2007 with business leaders
got very much have criticized for that
so
violence today all right well with all
of these violent attacks against these
symbols of the elite of luxury shops as
you mentioned what do the protesters
actually hope to achieve
well it's interesting I think to see why
these protests were so violent today and
I think we've got to take those in the
fact that the this big vast consultation
exercise which was undertaken by menu in
that corner two months ago the great
national debate as he calls it and this
came to an end yesterday through those
those meetings these numerous meetings
all around the country over the last two
months and the the president has been
trying to find out what the people want
what the the [ __ ] is Jean and the French
people in general want so they've been
with a great list of things that they're
asking for I think today the
demonstrators were saying look we've now
you see what we want now give it to us
or this violence is going to take place
I think for some of them as well let's
stop talking now it's time for
insurrection and there are definitely
people on these yellow vest rallies now
people who weren't there initially in
November but who got involved have got
involved since then who really wants ok
journalist John Lorenson reporting from
Paris many thanks